look what we brought back from Tokyo
it's a makima noodle stopper figure from
chainsaw man let's open her up
no wow the paintwork is actually pretty
good and the details on this figurine is
actually pretty awesome but it's time to
put that down and put this figure to the
test you see guys this is just normal
cup noodles problem I think everyone
will be able to relate
cutting cup noodle files just your
everyday problems but we won't be
needing a fog today okay let's Place
makima really carefully down oh she is
looking really really good that's it I
think this is really the Best Buy from
Japan now I can have makima watch Me
While I enjoy my noodles but if only she
could also sit on my face